in Berlin begrüße ich den
Politikwissenschaftler Albrecht von
Lucke wie wichtig war reichen für
Harbeck und die energiepolitischen Pläne
der Regierung
er war enorm wichtig ganz eindeutig sein
wichtigster Mann was die gesamte
heizungsklima ja dann jetzt ja auch
Wärmepumpen Thematik anbelangte deswegen
hat Robert Habeck so entschieden an ihm
festgehalten und man hat es ja eben
gehört er sagt selber es ist mit
schweren Konsequenzen für ihn behaftet
dass er ihn jetzt entlassen muss das
zeigt wie hart habe ich selbst damit
auch getroffen ist welche Auswirkungen
hat diese Geschichte denn jetzt auf die
Pläne des Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
zum Beispiel auf das Gebäude
Energiegesetz
das wird man noch sehen es ist ja die
ganz große Frage ob damit der Fall
reichen ausgestanden ist also wenn man
ihn als einen größeren Fall besteht
versteht der ja mittlerweile geworden
ist nämlich die Frage inwieweit das
Ministerium als solches unbeeinträchtigt
ist von den ich nenne es einmal
familienzusammenhängen die existiert den
engen Verbindungen von Menschen das muss
man sich über immer wieder bewusst
machen über lange Jahre hoch engagiert
zusammengearbeitet haben bei denen dann
auch familiäre Beziehung zustande
gekommen sind dieser Kasus ist ja noch
nicht in Gänze beseitigt und ich bin
ziemlich sicher dass die Opposition hier
massiv weiter schießen wird weiter
versuchen wird andere Verbindungen
herzustellen und das wird natürlich die
Unruhe im Ministerium sobald sobald
nicht zum zur Beruhigung kommen lassen
zumal ja noch ganz unklar ist wer der
Nachfolger von der gleichen wird auch
das eine ganz wichtige Personalie damit
Robert Habeck an den so wichtigen
Gesetzen seines Hauses weiter arbeiten
kann
ja diese Schüsse von denen sie gerade
Sprachen die sind ja heute schon
hörbarer geworden die Opposition fordert
schon einen Stopp der Reform und da gab
es da auch noch einen FDP Abgeordneten
der einen neuen Zeitplan will was
erwarten Sie
ja ich erwarte zumindest und das ist der
eigentlich springende Punkt dass das
Ministerium noch einmal sehr klar macht
das ist ja auch im Sinne des
Ministeriums selber wie die vielen
Fragen die noch im Raum sind beantwortet
werden können das große Malheur der
große Fehler war das hier bevor
überhaupt die die
Koalition jemals klar gemacht hätte das
tatsächlich Klimaschutz der zukünftige
Generation schützen will und soll das
hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht
ausdrücklich gesagt dass das immer auch
mit gewissen freiheitseinschränkungen
der Gegenwart der gegenwärtigen zu tun
hat das ist nie richtig erklärt worden
habe von daher mit seinem
wärmepumpengesetz das Land in erhebliche
Maße geschockt und jetzt muss natürlich
sozial abgefedert werden aber es ist
natürlich auch die ganz große Frage und
deswegen sprechen Sie die FDP zu Recht
an die große Frage ob die FDP endlich
ihren Koalition ihren Oppositionskurs in
der Koalition beendet denn das war ja
das Kernproblem von habe ich er hat es
nicht nur mit der Opposition aus cdu/csu
oder
besonders schlagkräftigen Teilen der
Medien stark vom Boulevard bestimmt zu
tun sondern die FDP selber hat auch
Opposition gegen Habeck gespielt und
daneben hat ein Kanzler zu alledem
weitgehend geschwiegen also von daher
ist eines erforderlich diese
klimakkoalition als die sie angetreten
ist muss jetzt auch wirklich einheitlich
als klimakondition agieren sonst wird
Habeck ist ganz ganz schwer fallen hier
noch einmal in die voranzukommen nun gab
es heute auch noch andere Reaktionen der
Bundesverband Energie und
Wasserwirtschaft beklagt dass die
Bundesregierung mit gleichen einen
ausgewiesenen international hoch
anerkannten Energiewende Experten
verliere wer könnte ihn ersetzen
ja das ist die ganz ganz große Frage und
vor allem ist natürlich eines auch
entscheidend es darf jetzt ganz
ersichtlich niemand sein der aus dem
engeren Dunst aus dem Umkreis von
Patrick reichen stammt das hat man ja
erlebt wie fatal das ist also wenn noch
einmal der Eindruck erweckt würde hier
ist gewissermaßen ein Netzwerk wieder
gemeinsam tätig der bekannten dann wäre
das fatal auf der anderen Seite muss man
eben immer sehen dass diese hoch
engagierten Menschen weitgehend bekannt
sind miteinander es ist eben doch ein
recht kleiner Kreis was man jetzt hört
das könnte ja sein dass der ehemalige
Umweltminister des Landes
Schleswig-Holstein Klaus Müller dass er
als Verbraucherschutz Experte dass er
möglicherweise diese Thematik übernimmt
das hört man das kann aber noch nicht
das letzte Momentum sein es wird jetzt
natürlich mit aller Energie nach einem
Mann gesucht der sowohl Erfahrung hat in
ministerieller Hinsicht aber auch in der
Fach Thematik schnell drin ist damit
diese Thematik weiter sachlich
bearbeitet werden kann denn umso mehr
Zeit verloren geht in der Personalfrage
umso schwerer wird es natürlich
beobachtet sein mit seinen
Gesetzesplänen wieder nach vorne zu
kommen sie sagten gerade ehemaliger
Umweltminister Schleswig-Holstein das
klingt jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig
weit entfernt
leider haben sie recht das war Robert
habe ich auch einmal wenn Sie das meinen
aber das heißt natürlich nicht dass zwei
Personen die das gleiche Amt bekleidet
haben nun unbedingt familiär vertraut
sind zu meiner dazu sagen muss wir haben
es ja hier nicht mit dem
Umweltministerium zu tun aber sie haben
schon recht das Grundproblem wird sein
nachdem jetzt gerade in einem so großen
Zusammenhang der Eindruck ja einer
gewissen ich will es nicht Vettern
Wirtschaft und es wäre ganz in Form wie
es zum Teil die CSU tut von Clan
Wirtschaft zu sprechen das ist ja quasi
die Kriminalisierung der Verbindung aber
es ist zumindest so es sind sehr enge
verwandtschaftliche Verbindungen auch
familiäre das darf nicht eintreten und
das ist natürlich tatsächlich in dieser
Szene nicht so ganz leicht die Leute
kennen sich sie sind über Jahre
zusammengewachsen sie haben lange
engagiert zusammengearbeitet hier muss
Robert habe ich also besonders aufpassen
dass sie nicht das Gleiche mal wieder
passiert das jetzt gerade aufgeflogen
ist
vielen Dank für diese Einordnungen
ich danke Ihnen